so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about Iceman Bobby Drake and
why he's considered to be an omega-level
mutant and what I'm hoping is that at
the end of this video you'll have a
better understanding of his powers as
well as how they've changed over the
course of his publication history
so first things first I want to take a
second to provide some clarity on what
it means to be an omega-level mutant so
those who are deemed to be omega-level
mutant sin Marvel Comics receive this
classification in one of two ways either
it's within the comics when someone
refers to a mutant powers as being a
limitless or spy a writer for Marvel
themselves within the comics the
classification of omega-level usually
comes from the idea that at their full
potential the powers of a particular
mutant cannot be surpassed look into
individuals who can control reality all
matter in existence ranging from the air
we breathe to the water we drink and the
ground we walk on is composed of atoms
and a collection of these atoms are
called molecules taking a character like
Mad Jim Jasper's he's able to take the
molecules of a substance and restructure
them to create something else as an
example rubbing alcohol is composed of
two hydrogen and two oxygen atoms
usually referred to as h2o - using his
abilities to control matter Jim Jasper's
could restructure a cup of rubbing
alcohol and eliminate one of the oxygen
atoms turning it into h2o also known as
water while not all mutants are capable
of this level of control in terms of
people who can warp reality the Omega
level classification is designed to tell
us that they could essentially bring an
end to everything in the universe now
looking to telepaths like Emma Frost
Clinton choir or Jean Grey the Omega
level classification is designed to tell
us that there are no telepaths in Marvel
Comics capable of exceeding their levels
of telepathy
instead all other telepaths are either
equal to their power or less powerful
now having said that I want to start
this video on ice man off with the
original depiction of his powers and
move forward from there so when Bobby
Drake first appeared in mobile comics
with x-men issue number one during this
time Stan Lee and Jack Kirby we're still
fleshing out the idea of powers and what
means for capable of what I mean here is
that at the time of the x-men's creation
models roster of super-powered
earthbound heroes consisted a Spider Man
The Incredible Hulk and the Fantastic
Four
all of whom derived their abilities from
cosmic rays or some form of radiation to
this end the
abilities were simple to flesh out and
that they were rooted in science and
could easily be grasped by the reader on
the other hand because these characters
were so popular Marvel had to create
mutants in a way that ensure their
powers would still be impressive but
wouldn't come off as a copy of
established abilities as a result while
the rest of the x-men as they were
introduced included Cyclops with optic
beams Jean Grey with telekinesis hate
McCoy with enhanced strength and agility
as well as angel with physical wings
Iceman was established as being someone
who had the power to manipulate the cold
now the basic premise of these abilities
is something that I'd like you to keep
in the back of your mind and the reason
why is that over the course of this
video we'll transition through the
evolution of his abilities culminating
in his classification as an omega-level
mutant and what exactly it is that he's
doing when he uses his powers now
regarding his original appearance since
the comics were targeted towards young
readers and the x-men themselves were
teenagers the powers of Iceman reflected
this and that he was simply depicted as
a snowman now an important distinction
to make here is that Bobby Drake is not
physically turning himself into snow
instead he's providing himself with a
snowy covering that's akin to icy snow
which were texturing from conventional
weapons some new Marvel also established
early on was that Bobby had the power to
create various defensive constructs out
of snow including ramps and boxes
capable of repelling cyclopses optic
beams as well as offensive constructs
like snow grenades which encompass other
objects blanketing them in snow and
actually freezing them in the process
now the way the Bobby Drake does this is
by literally bringing hydrogen and
oxygen atoms together to form water and
then freezing them to create objects or
surround himself with snow now I'd like
you to keep this in the back of your
mind since this will be one half of the
equation that will go on to establish
why Iceman is omega-level but following
these first depictions of his powers the
constructs available to Iceman began to
expand including virtually anything you
wish to create with x-men issue number
four providing us with our first view of
Bobby Drake creating ice ramps allowing
him to slide from one location to
another
however Marvel also established that
there were limits to ice man's abilities
as well as weaknesses as an example
Bobby Drake was originally only able to
affect objects
within his field of view meaning that he
couldn't arbitrarily freeze an object on
the other side of the world in addition
to this temperatures as high as 212
degrees which is where water converts to
steam were capable of melting Bobby snow
exterior as well as melting the
constructs that he created now following
this emphasis was put on Bobby Drake
fine-tuning his abilities and was
reflected in issue number six which
provided him with a more human
appearance while encased in snow in
addition to this with issue number seven
the snow appearance of Bobby Drake and
his constructs began to reflect an icy
air appearance with the walls that he
created showing to have icicles with
more of a bluish hue and initially
number 28 Marvel established that he was
able to take on an icy form that could
actually make him almost transparent
however because these early comics
functioned to establish the foundations
of the expence abilities between issue
number four and the cancellation and
reboot of this series with issue number
94 not much changed in terms of his
powers instead focus was placed on
creating a more well-rounded
representation of his abilities with
issue number 64 maintaining that his
weakness was still rooted in extremely
high temperatures something that was
carried over to the X Factor line under
Bob Layton and Louise Simonson to
sidetrack for a second if you guys
recall my videos on the history of the
x-men we had talked about how the
relaunch of the series focus on the
introduction of a new team with the
original x-men taking a backseat as a
result Iceman was among those characters
who had a series of spotty appearances
between 1975 and 1986 leading up to the
launch of x-factor now where Bob Layton
did not last long on the x-factor title
and departed after only four or five
issues on the whole Bobby Drake saw
virtually no expansion on his abilities
during this time in truth during the
entire run of x-factor ice Man's powers
largely remain the same as they did
during the latter half of the original
x-men title prior to its cancellation
the reason for this was that the
x-factor title was not designed to
expand on the abilities of heroes
instead because it involved characters
that we were already familiar with the
x-factor line focused largely on story
based content introducing villains like
apocalypse and his four horsemen as well
as seeing the fall of war in Worthington
when he became the horseman death
as a result it wasn't until uncanny
x-men issue number 314 under Scott
Liddell that Iceman was elevated to a
mega level status not a sidetrack for a
second prior to her Reformation and
joining the x-men the mutant telepath
Emma Frost was a long-standing member of
the Hellfire clubs inner circle as an
organization composed of powerful
mutants who were also extremely wealthy
during this time it was led by Sebastian
Shaw I meet with the ability to convert
energy into physical strength and the
organization functioned to influence
world events in their favor were these
efforts range from financing Stephen
Lang Sentinel project to capturing Jean
Grey during the Dark Phoenix saga the
group also had students of their own in
a manner akin to the x-men referred to
as the Hellions these young mutants were
trained by Emma Frost personally at her
Massachusetts Academy and were formed in
response to Charles Xavier x-men and new
Butte ins however in uncanny x-men issue
number 282 which coincided with the
introduction of Bishop a beautiful the
future named Trevor Fitzroy along with
an army of signals destroyed the
Hellions by absorbing their life
energies and which will allow Fitzroy to
power his own abilities to create
portals and travel through time in
addition to this during the battle and
in an act of desperation
Emma Frost place yourself in a coma
during which time she was discovered by
the x-men and taken to the Xavier
Institute now picking up with uncanny
x-ray and issue number 314 this story
saw Emma Frost consciousness waking up
and with Iceman being the first person
she saw her mind quite literally seize
control of his body now where the
intention of Emma was to discover what
had happened to the Hellions in order to
function adequately she began the
process of acquainting herself with
Bobby Drake's body during this time
frost discovered that in his ice form
Bobby Drake hits the same physical
injury including being shot through the
chest or losing an arm but as the damage
could be repaired by using the moisture
in the air to literally reform himself
in addition to this Emma discovered that
Iceman has the power to convert himself
to a water or gaseous state making him
virtually immune to physical harm
now while this revelation is only
covered in a single page what Marvel is
telling us is that because Iceman
possesses the ability to control the
molecules of water because 4% of the
Earth's atmosphere is water vapor and
71% of the planet is covered in water
ice man's abilities have an infinite
source of fuel and are essentially
limitless following this lead over the
course of the next 10 years between 1994
and 2014
different writers have expanded on how
the limitless nature of ice man's powers
can be applied as an example in x-men
vol 2 issue number 41 during the events
of Legion quests which sought Legion
killing Xavier and causing the Age of
Apocalypse storyline following the death
of Charles Iceman froze all of the water
and legions body and while Legion did
survive after melting the ice this was
expanded on in 2008 following the
release of x-men manifest destiny
focusing on the x-men moving its
headquarters to San Francisco out of New
York during an interview with comic book
resources butter Mike Harry had stated
that have pushed to their absolute
limits ice man's abilities would allow
him to control reality itself
to expand on this if you've ever taken a
chemistry or physics course you'll know
that heat is something a byproduct of
molecules moving at extremely high
speeds and cold as a byproduct of
molecules moving at extremely low speeds
as a result the term absolute zero is
used to define what happens when there's
no molecular movement of any kind
meaning that when Iceman uses his powers
in addition to manipulating the atoms of
hydrogen and oxygen to create water
he's also slowing down the movement of
molecules to create cold to this end
while this type of control is limited to
his immediate vicinity if given enough
training the ability to control
molecules could expand to all of space
and time with that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end and
make sure you guys supposed to comment
down below and let me know which
omega-level mutant you think we should
discuss next and I will catch you guys
later peace
you